don't break anything
oh no it's like i'm a vampire i don't
want to be a vampire uh-oh
never
limit yourself to the tools that you
have keep your horizons broad today i am
making the plunge i have decided to
start learning cinema 4d so for the last
several years everyone here at the
studio minus the clone have been using
what is called 3ds max a program that
allows you to manipulate 3d models and
render them do simulations all kinds of
crazy cool stuff but there's lots of
different 3d packages out there and
probably the biggest one i think because
it's the most supported has the most
tutorials has the most plug-ins and most
of the people i follow on instagram that
make 3d stuff they all use this program
called cinema 4d
[Music]
cinema 4d is very well supported so many
annoyances and struggles and problems
with 3ds max because it is not supported
i just shot the painting one thing that
i do like about cinema 4d so far is just
how fast it loads i'm going to load 3ds
max you just you just clicked it i just
clicked 3ds max
at this point i'll usually go
grab a snack
oh now it's loaded but it's not actually
fully loaded just yet
this is 3ds next 2018 by the way
okay now it's loaded fully there i can
start using stuff i can open up projects
i'm gonna exit it out
i've already exited it
now watch cinema 4d clicked it it takes
a moment for the splash screen to show
up but once it once it actually does
show up look at this
done look
like ready to use i just realized
something carmichael the license i have
for octane is only for 3ds max i think
it's like five or six hundred dollars i
think they have a subscription
but i was i gotta you gotta show the
scorpion it's so big on my mouth step
one
cut a hole in the box no i mean download
the software great auction grab everyone
watching the coil
then come up with a sweet shot to make
there's actually a plan for that i have
a shot in mind that i want to make
[Music]
i've managed to install cinema 4d and it
works i've also now started watching
some tutorials i have forgotten that
watching tutorials can be really
dry
yeah i've now managed to buy a
subscription to octane render but i'm
having this problem it's not working
two meters by two meters wow that's not
that big oh gosh okay
there are shortcuts that are throwing me
off here i'm sure i could probably go
into the shortcuts and i can change it
to be the way i like what if i add in
a capsule figure
a human body
human body so i've got oh i've got my
viewport movement down to just the
middle mouse button so i can move it and
then i can press the alt key in into
view yeah change the view i am one step
closer i have now figured out how to
implement the octane lighting system i
mean step two we're gonna figure out how
to put an hdr in oh i also gotta learn
how to freaking camera track
my throat is drying up
that didn't really help
books are some of my favorite things
because stories are great and they're so
much longer than what you get in a movie
sure a movie might be more visceral but
books books are where it's at and
listening to books
[Music]
today we're talking about star wars did
you see the last jedi i personally liked
it but a lot of people didn't for
whatever reason this book that i'm going
to talk about today is called heir to
the empire it's part of the thrawn
trilogy and it's a fantastic book series
and this is why
okay uh let's try to make this
interesting
don't break anything you want to get on
the front
okay so before i talk about
why the book's really cool
using the code corner crew if you text
it you can text it
if you are an amazon prime member
you can actually get audible for 4.95
you can actually get
the audible subscriptions for 4.95 a
month for three months that's like
getting two months for free
to get that you got to go to audible.com
oh god
they go to audible.com corridor crew or
you can actually text message quarter
crew one word to 500 500 oh
and if you're not an amazon prime member
that's okay because you can get like the
regular 30-day subscription now the book
that i want to talk about is called air
to the empire it's the first of a
trilogy so if you get the first one you
have another two months to get the other
two oh god oh no
so this book takes place about five
years after the events of return of the
jedi so this the death star is destroyed
vader is dead the empire's gone but this
book is no longer canon because disney
made all of star wars before the news
the new trilogy like non-canon anymore
so this is like an alternate universe
[Music]
where this is actually starting to work
man you got luke skywalker han solo you
got c3po even i mean lando and han solo
team up and it's a merry old time
i think we're actually starting to get
our groove going this is working here
let me take the camera from you
oh man carmichael this is working far
better than i expected
this book is widely considered to be one
of like the why are you leaning that way
oh no so okay
so one of the things that i think sets
this book apart this is the 20th
anniversary series of this book is the
production value and let me talk to
adrian about what exactly i mean by that
i got pants
it's not gonna work we can make it
happen
not only is the narrator really good and
he does solid impressions of like all
the original star wars characters music
like star wars music and sound effects
and like background audio that's very
immersive
so like you got the music wow the voice
came softly but insistently
[Music]
[Music]
greatly and i'm afraid that it will be
longer still until the next time
no way this is with han solo at a bar
why not
because you've gone respectable for now
maybe
like a 13-hour book yeah but it has it
has just enough like aspects to it to
make you feel like you're watching a
movie or a show or something it's very
immersive and so it's like a 13-hour
movie of star wars apparently written
like 25 years ago
28 years ago that's older than peter
usual are you amazon prime yeah since
you are an amazon prime subscriber you
can get an audible subscription for 4.95
a month for three months and i just like
any book yeah hey right
i'm an amazon friend number can i get
audible for five dollars a month for
4.95 a month all you got to do is go to
audible.com corridor crew or or you can
text message quarter crew one word to
500 500 that's that sounds like a deal
i'm doing it in fact i've listened to
lots of books i have some others that i
would like to talk about here is a list
of some of them and you should let me
know in the comments which one i should
talk about next
so i guess i should probably film a shot
i'm going to use something that i've
been wanting to do for a little while
which is use my favorite camera in the
whole world the insta 360 one it's a 360
camera i want to just have some sort of
chrome figure just scanning here but for
it to be chrome it has to have something
to reflect and that's where this comes
in this is going to give us a video
reflection plate
time reflections of someone walking
around it so if i have some sort of
chrome model here it'll reflect the
person as they walk around it
you might notice here i have a slightly
different 360 camera this one actually
belongs to vsauce it doesn't belong to
me i've been borrowing it for the last
few months this isn't to get a
reflection pass this is going to
actually capture several stops of light
in 360 so that i will have an image that
actually influences the light of the
scene see the skylights of above as
sources of light i will combine those
images into one super high dynamic range
photo and use that to influence the
light so between this and the video
camera i'll be able to get a nice
accurate representation of the real
environment here but in cg i wanted to
give you guys a pro tip about motion
tracking how do you prep your footage so
that it can be tracked more easily and
more accurately at least i this is how i
used to do it i used to just add levels
crank up the contrast
overall across the whole shot problem
with that is that you end up losing
detail when you do that and then you
don't have anywhere to track on say like
a wall of the ground this way you add a
crap ton of detail without actually
destroying the footage so here is my
footage with no effects applied most
people do in these situations they will
literally add sharpness that's not what
you want to add what you want to add is
a few different instances of unsharp
mask what is unsharp mask finds like
places where there's contrast and then
just increases the contrast very locally
in that spot and you can adjust the
radius at which it's doing that i'll add
a few different effects of unsharp mask
no contrast with contrast so i'll have a
radius of around 50 another at 20 and
then another at five motion tracking so
much easier i can track this point here
because i can easily see it without the
instruct mask
boom it's
really hard to make out from the rest of
the footage so if there's any amount of
motion blur it disappears actually i
really like this little dude as like a
test subject so i ended up just kind of
delicating i ended up just kind of
duplicating him a few times and adding a
few different textures to kind of just
figure out some cool stuff so we got
like chrome material right here in the
front but i also made like a little like
goldish foil type material i also made
like a plastic red material and of
course my favorite
ice the the materials here are actually
all fairly simple what's interesting
about this is that i actually have the
real lighting from where we shot the
video and i'll show you that here now
currently there is no light in the scene
just ambient light now if i turn on the
actual image based lighting boom so as
you can see you have like the light
coming down from the skylights hitting
the top of each of these models so
they're a little brighter up there if i
change the exposure you'll be able to
see what i'm talking about so my
exposure is set to one right now but if
i drop it down
you can see how the bright spots on the
reflection of the skylights are actually
showing up the most because that's what
it'd be like if you were to stop down
the exposure on a camera it looks great
but the problem is that my reflection is
not there it's like i'm a vampire i
don't want to be a vampire fortunately i
can prevent vampire isis by putting in
the 360 image code name garlic
reflection of the hdr and reflection of
the video so now as i actually get
closer to the camera you can see my
reflection pop up and this is what i was
wanting i wanted to get right up against
it and wave and you can see me all
distorted like i'm actually looking at
some boldest thing like that it should
look a lot like that i'm happy with my
materials i'm happy with my lighting i'm
happy with my scene i'm happy with my
marriage i'm happy with my job yeah i'm
happy with world affairs
you're not i'm not i really like these
materials now but the models can be
improved and so to do that the whole
point of me starting this thing is i
wanted to make a terminator and
fortunately i don't have to know how to
model the terminator because there is a
free version of the terminator available
online that i can download and use try
that again i don't need to know how to
model the terminator because i have time
travel
friday rendered took 15 hours there are
560 frames so it's 18 seconds long uh
let's use terminators
yes i'm excited
so this is actually the first time i'm
previewing the shot as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn the little terminator man this is
amazing wow
that's crazy
are you gonna transfer over from 3ds max
yeah a lot does transfer over for sure
are you going to transfer over oh yes am
i going to transfer i think so how long
do you think it'll take you to transfer
over i'm ready to do it we got some we
got some 3d stakes for prim tech to do
what's going to do in the cinema cool
i'm excited cool this looks great it's
awesome very nice work
you're pleased with it
i am really happy you stuck around on
this journey with me thank you for
watching and i'm just really happy i
know how to use cinema 4d now and i
believe you can too there's tutorials
for all this stuff online grayscale
gorilla is a fantastic resource but
really when it comes down to learning
something you have to give yourself a
goal you have to have something to aim
for if you don't have that you might as
well be wasting your time here i
specifically had a shot in mind that i
had planned and that wanted to create i
wanted to create this shot but in order
to do that i had to learn this program
and get through the steps of doing that
to make this shot if i didn't have this
shot i would have been like
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing anymore
thank you for watching and subscribe to
the corridor crew channel